des files d'attentes interminables des
gens qui dorment un peu partout des
centaines de valise abandonnée
cette famille temps de se rendre dans
les maritimes pour des funérailles
vendredi
ils sont ici depuis 24 heures trois de
leurs valises ont disparu
des centaines de personnes sont coincées
à l'aéroport depuis des heures dans
certains cas des jours les vols retardés
ou annulés par manque de personnel ont
des conséquences désastreuses ce groupe
d'élèves est ici depuis trente six
heures est possible de trouver un vol
pour retourner aux états unis et comme
on est un groupe de 19 on dit que c'est
trop compliqué et puis on à la compagnie
avec laquelle on a bouclé un tour et il
travaille aussi mais à canada ne répond
cet autre américain qui tente de se
rendre à calgary passe le temps en
s'entraînant il est ici depuis 24 heures
et la valise de sa conjointe est
introuvable
cet homme cherche la valise de sa mère
depuis dix jours dans le système on voit
que le bagage n'a été localisé à
montréal est et il avait été auparavant
envoyé en allemagne or c'est pas sa
destination finale donc depuis le 18
j'attends plusieurs voyageurs déplore le
manque de communication et de
coordination de la part des compagnies
aériennes pour reprendre le contrôle de
la situation
des vols au cours des prochains jours
seront annulés il faut faire le choix
difficiles de en levée de destination ou
de mettre les gens dans une situation
qui est insupportable donc je crois que
le choix de délester sera sera chose
d'anodin t nitoo had more i saw the
world team honda à
tous
reste à voir si cette initiative
fonctionnera l'objectif est de retrouver
un certain équilibre dans les arts ou
par d'ici la mi-juillet ici marichelles
aux ondes radio canada montréal